Ian Black Mr Blackford it's always good
to talk to you um just your reaction uh
too well the the forthcoming election of
Rishi sunak is prime minister well first
and foremost let me give my
congratulations to Richie soon I can
becoming prime minister it is a pretty
significant moment in a shared political
history to see a British age and become
Prime Minister I think that in itself is
a a good sign to see the breadth and
depths of our culture across these
islands
um and to see that we need to see people
across all backgrounds represented in in
public life not least in in politics so
from that standpoint I I welcome him I
hope that we have a a positive
relationship he has a positive
relationship with the devolved
administrations and I I look forward to
working with them when we can do so over
issues such as Ukraine of course but but
obviously reaching out to him and saying
that he needs to recognize that there is
a democratic mandate in Scotland for the
Scottish Parliament to move ahead with
an independence referendum so in a
respectful way I look forward to the
relationship that we have but we'll also
have to say to him that he is the third
20 prime minister in three months I
think the public are calling for a
general election that I think it's right
that we move to that position and allow
the people across all these islands to
have their say in the future that they
want to have a future say in the
government of the United Kingdom but of
course in Scotland being able to
demonstrate quite fully that we deserve
that right to have our independence
referendum
so so when Nicholas sturgeon became
first minister with a vote back in 2014.
I mean you know you you took that
straight to the Scottish Scottish
electorate well we did have a Scottish
parliamentary election we've had several
since then of course Neil and the first
Minister has been returned at every time
I think there is a world of difference
in someone that has a Mandy and of
course under our system it's quite right
that you do have under certain
circumstances change of leadership but
not what we've faced over the course of
the the recent past the turmoil the
crashing of the financial markets and I
think a conservative government that has
fallen massively out of favor with the
electorate it's under those
circumstances that the right thing to do
morally and of course there are
conservative MPS that are also calling
for that election and and of course I
know the issue here is how do we get
that but there is within the gift of the
leader of the opposition Kirsten that
ability to lay a vote of no confidence
and I think it's right that all of us
take our responsibilities that we say to
conservative MPS that they've lost that
moral authority to lead the law
authority to govern and we should test
the will of the House of Commons to see
if people are prepared to stand up and
do the right thing but as my old
colleague Oliver Brown once said that he
shiver ran along the front bench of the
labor front bench to see if there was a
spine that could crawl up so we really
need some backbone from the labor party
to accept responsibility enforcing that
vote of no confidence
it's a good line I will grant you that
Mr Blackford but at the same time is now
the right moment for either a vote of no
confidence or for a snap general
election to be called I mean if you were
to get your wish we would be talking
about the best part of two months of
chaos again wouldn't we have in a
general election campaign surely what
the country wants right now and at least
for now you may well choose to change
your mind to come the new year when we
see what Rishi sunak does but surely
they at least deserve the opportunity to
have a go at it to try and steady the
ship I mean we've already seen the
markets coming
well of course what we've seen is people
paying the price for the mistakes of the
conservative government the massive
increase that we've had in mortgage
rates and that remains the case Neil
that people are going to be paying a
price for this and I think it's right
that the conservatives are judged by
that but what I really feared this
morning that when we should be looking
at how yes of course we need to see
stability in the financial markets but
we should for example be looking at a
windfall tax and those that have
benefited from the cost of energy crisis
that we have but my real fear is that
we're going to see austerity 2.0 and
that can't be allowed to happen so there
are real differences real divides that
we have but we certainly can't be in the
situation that the poor and the most
vulnerable we're having to pick up the
tab for the failure of Tory economic
management
so what then given that he isn't calling
an election today and given that he will
be moving forward we presume at least
for the time being with that statement
on the 31st and what do you want to hear
from Rishi sunak and the chancellor to
try and sort out the economy well I mean
I've given that example we could be
looking at a a winfall tax but we
certainly should not be looking to cuts
to public services but let's get that
financial statement on Monday let's uh
the labor party should bring forward
that vote of no confidence and let's
test the House of Commons as to whether
or not we're prepared to respect what
the public wants and that's a general
election
and just some a final thought Mr
Blackford on Liz truss of course we're
expecting her to pop out of Downing
Street around about quarter past ten
having held that final cabinet and make
her final statement as prime minister is
there just in just in personal terms is
there part of you that feels some degree
of sympathy for her
look it's been a tragedy for for those
trust but I mean I will reflect on the
damage that she has caused the fact that
mortgage holders as a as an example are
going to have to pay a price but nobody
wants to see somebody humiliated and I
suspect as the first Minister said that
Liz trust is going to be a footnote in
history but of course I wish her and her
family all the best at the end of this
period
in Blackfoot always good to see you
thanks for joining us this morning thank
you